a passenger jet pushes through a shroud
of white as it takes off from Chiang Mai
this isn't low-lying Cloud it's fine
particle pollution known as PM 2.5 and
it's been hanging over Northern Thailand
for the past three months
Chiang Mai hospital has been inundated
with patients complaining of breathing
difficulties rashes and skin irritations
but doctors say the problems are much
more serious
PM 2.5 can cause brain tumors and heart
and lung diseases but it's rarely
identified as the root cause when we
write the their certificate we say that
they die from cardiovascular disease we
never say that they die from pm2 qualify
that that is fairly difficult yeah
this is a big part of the problem shrubs
burnt off in the forest that cover the
whole of Northern Thailand by the
villagers that live in these areas in
the hope that the ash left behind when
the monsoon rain comes will leave
fertile ground for growing mushrooms and
other vegetables
but it's the mass burning of
agricultural waste sugarcane and corn
that's the real culprit large Agro
businesses take the end product leaving
Farmers to burn off What's Left Behind
this is happening across Thailand
Myanmar Laos and Cambodia making the
region one of the most polluted in the
world
chair the Parliamentary subcommittee on
PM 2.5 pollution it recommended the
government subsidized Farmers not to
burn their waste
but nothing happened and he thinks he
knows why the problem is because of the
big company
their support some parties and also
support the military
prime minister himself braved the smoke
to go out campaigning there's an
election next month
so the question
you had eight years in power why have
you done nothing about the pollution
this Nursery School is having air
filters fitted pollution this bad can
cut life expectancy by three to five
years
children are particularly vulnerable
but as they settle down for their
afternoon nap even if it's only for a
couple of hours
these kids will finally have clean air
to breathe
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Chiang Mai
Thailand